this is joint work with
shaman orion on
so first i'll talk a little bit about
trace reconstruction for linear strings
which is
the standard tracer construction that
has been studied before
so the setup is that we have an unknown
binary string
x of land n it's going to be passed
through a deletion channel which deletes
each bit of
the string with some fixed probability q
the resulting bits are going to be
concatenated into
a trace and that's what we see so we
want to construct
reconstruct the original string from
seeing a lot of independent traces so
the question is
how can we do this and how many traces
do we need to recover the string with
high probability
so for example let's say the unknown
string is this string here
and let's say q is about a half so
it'll be passed through the deletion
channel and
these bits marked in red will be deleted
and then um what we see is the result of
concatenating
all of the remaining bits together so we
see 1 1
0 and 1 1 0 and we want to determine
what the original string is after seeing
many different traces
like this
so the motivation for this problem comes
from some questions in
computational biology studying dna so
first there's the multiple sequence
alignment problem where
given dna sequences from lots of
descendants you want to
determine the sequence of the ancestor
and there's also the question of dna
storage where
dna data is stored in some dna
and we can read the data by sequencing
though this is somewhat noisy and
for example some bits might be deleted
in the process
so some previous results in trace
reconstruction for linear strings
so for worst case reconstruction by
which we mean
we want to be able to reconstruct any
arbitrary string
of length n uh so first we have
uh hole and sin at all showed that we
can do this in
e to the roughly square root of n traces
uh then simultaneously nazareth and
perez and day o'donnell and cervedio
improve this to
e to the roughly cube root of n and very
recently
chase improved this to e to the roughly
n to the one-fifth
there's also the case of average case
reconstruction in which
the unknown string x is uniformly is
randomly chosen uniformly at random from
all length n strings
and in this case hollinson at all showed
that
if the deletion probability is small
enough we can do this
in polynomially many traces
this is improved by present di to
e to the roughly square root of log n if
the deletion probability is less than
a half and hold incremental and perez
showed that for all deletion
probabilities we can do this in each of
the roughly cube root of log
n finally there's
the question of lower bounds so how many
traces are required for both worst case
reconstruction and average case
reconstructed
holden and leon showed that um you need
at least n to the five fourths for worst
case and log into the 9 4
for average case and this is improved by
chase to enter the three halves and log
into the five halves
uh so the new variant that we introduce
is circular trees reconstruction
and it's essentially the same except
instead of linear binary strings we have
cyclic binary strings or circular binary
strings
of length n and we're just passing them
through a deletion channel probability
q and the results are concatenated
the remaining bits are concatenated into
smaller circular strings
and we want to reconstruct the original
string
up to cyclic rotation
so equivalently it's a linear
trace reconstruction except the string
will undergo a random cyclic rotation
before entering the deletion channel so
we can just pick
an arbitrary point in the circle to
start the string
so for example let's say we have this
linear string on the left
it'll pass through the deletion channel
and
all the bits marked in red will be
deleted the resulting bits are
concatenated into the smaller circular
string
and we can read it as a linear string by
choosing an arbitrary
bit to start the string at so the
question is
can we achieve similar bounds on the
sample complexity compared to
a linear tracer construction
so now i'm going to talk a little bit
about our results
uh so first for worst case circular
trace reconstruction
where we have some arbitrary unknown
circular string
x and it's going to go through a
deletion channel probability q
then with high probability
we can recover x using e to the
roughly and a cube root of n independent
traces up to log factors in the exponent
provided that n is the product of atoms
2 prime so n is
prime it's uh the square root of prime
or is the product of two different
primes
and the reason for this dependence on
the prime factorization of n
is that a certain part of our algorithm
relies on a number theoretical condition
that only holds for these m
there's also uh we also have results in
average case circular
trace reconstruction where we have a
random circular string
x of length n
that goes through some constant
probability deletion channel
and in this case we can recover x using
polynomially many choices though the
exponent will depend on the deletion
probability q
finally we have a lower bound for worst
case circular trace reconstruction
where we showed that up to log factors
we need at least
n cubed independent traces to recover
the string with higher probability
um so this is higher compared to um
the n to the three halves known for
linear strings
so now i'll sort of go through our
proofs
so for worst case reconstruction we have
again
an arbitrary unknown circular string x
of length n it goes through a deletion
channel of
probability q and as long as n is the
product of that most two primes
then we can with high probability
determine what the original unknown
string was
using e to the o of n to the one third
traces up to log factors in the exponent
so the main idea of our algorithm is
that
um we want to construct a certain
polynomial
q of z of x q of zx where it's a
polynomial in z that depends on x
and we want to find an unbiased
estimator for this polynomial
that we can compute just based on the
traces of x
and essentially the idea is that we want
to answer the question
of whether traces we see are coming from
some string x or some string y
so in order to do this uh we first need
that
this polynomial q is not too large of
magnitude for
the values of z that we're plugging in
and we need
that um q of z x and q zy differ
significantly for some z
if x and y are different so
the idea is that uh we can use our
unbiased estimator
to estimate um uh
that we can take the average of uh
the values we see from evaluating the
unbiased estimator and see if they're
closer to q
z x or q zy and if x
is the original string then with high
probability
it will be much closer to q zx than q zy
and if we run this through all pairs of
strings then we'll see that
x will win in every pair and then with
high probability x will be
the string we can conclude that x is the
original string
so this is essentially the same argument
used for
linear trace reconstruction except
we need to come up with some different
polynomial q to handle
circular strings so in particular this q
should be invariant up to cyclic
permutations in x
and the reason we can't handle n with
too many prime factors is that
in order to encode this circular string
condition um
we need to use nth roots of unity in our
construction
and uh and these enter to unity are less
well behaved
for and with too many prime factors and
um
we need certain arithmetic properties
from these roots of unity for our
algorithm
uh so for the unbiased estimator first
let me define the polynomial q
so for linear strings y we can define
this polynomial p
z y where we just write the bits into
the coefficients
so it'll be a degree n polynomial
where the coefficients are y1 through yn
and then
for every circular string x we define q
zx to be
the sum of this expression over all
rotations y of x
by which we mean start from either
linear strings resulting from starting
from each bit in x
and so we're summing z to the 2n times p
of z y squared
times t of 1 over z squared y over all
rotations y of x
uh so uh notably when z is an nth root
root of unity every term in this sum is
equal
and the way to see this is that to note
that if you because
if z is an nth word immunity if you
shift y over by one
bit then p of z y squared will multiply
by z squared and p of one over z squared
y will divide by z squared so the
expression remains unchanged
and so um we can show that there exists
a function
h of a trace that takes a trace of x and
z
such that the expectation um
of this overall traces is equal to q z x
so this is what allows us to estimate q
z x
uh given many traces of x
and so this is our unbiased estimator
and in order to
use this we need certain bounds on q and
h
so first we need that h is bounded in
magnitude so we can apply a sure enough
bound so
um we have uh we'll be using z on the
unit circle close to one so
depending on a parameter l we'll have
z vary along the arc of the unit circle
near one
of length one over l and we have this
bound on h in terms of l
we also want um if
um x and y are different strings for q
of z x and q of z y to be far apart
and so we have this result where as long
as q z x and q z y
are different as polynomials
then for some z along this arc they will
be
uh sufficiently far apart for
us to distinguish x and y um and this is
essentially just a turn off bound
and once we have enough traces
with high probability
if x is the correct string then the
average overall
evaluations of h will be closer much
closer to q zx than q z y
uh now the issue here is uh whether q z
x
and q zy are different as polynomials um
so again we define p z y
and q z x for linear strings y and
circular strings x
so q z x um because we're summing over
all rotations of x
if we cyclically shift x
uh then this uh q zx remains unchanged
but there's a possibility that for
different cyclic strings
um x and x prime q z x and q z x prime
turn out to be the same
because we're summing over all rotations
so the question is um
when can we distinguish between
different circular strings x and y
using uh q z x
and so using some um after some
computations
in the cycloatomic field
of the antimode of unity we can
reduce this so first
note that by what we said before
for um for root of unity z every term in
the sum
um is equal so
uh to demonstrate that q zx and qzy are
not equal as polynomials we just need to
show that for some root of unity z
uh they're not equal hence for sum root
of unity z
um the individual term p of z squared
times p of one over z squared
uh these terms are not equal so we want
this um
to be true if these two terms are equal
for x and y for all
enthusiasm z then x y rotations
and after some computations in the sick
atomic field this can
uh we can show that this follows from um
the simpler condition which is that um
whenever
uh pz the ratio of pzx to pzy
is an nth root of unity for all which we
need z then x and y
are rotations of each other so it's easy
to see that the converse of this
always holds so if x and y are shifted
um if y is a shift of x by a fact by k
positions then this ratio will always
just be z to the k but this statement
only holds um this statement is true if
and only if n has most two prime factors
so when n has um more than two prime
factors
there is a counter example that shows
that
for different circular strings um you
can get the same
result so this algorithm won't work for
those values of that
okay so to summarize the algorithm let's
say we have some unknown
arbitrary circular string of length and
x and n is a product of
at minus two primes uh so that we're
going to be
testing every pair of distinct circular
strings
of whether it's more likely
that the traces are coming from y one or
y two
and to do this uh we consider q y one q
z y one and q z y two
and um so because n is
the product of atmosphere primes the two
polynomials are different
and so for this certain choice of the
parameter l
we can look at the arc on the unit
circle and we can find some z along the
arc
such that q z y 1 and q y 2 differ by
a large enough amount then we can
average
our unbiased estimator over all the
traces of the unknown string
and we can look at if the average is
closer to q zy1 or qzy2
and with high probability um
the correct string x is going to win
every pair it's in
uh so there's going to be some unique
string x that wins in every pair
it's in and we just return that string
as the answer
and so because h is bounded we can apply
a sure enough bound
and union bound over all pairs to show
that this will succeed with high
probability
so this gives a result
and so uh we were only concerned here
with the sample complexity so this
algorithm here is horribly inefficient
there are techniques for doing this
reconstruction more efficiently
using some linear programming and this
has been done already
for linear trace reconstruction
so now for the average case
we have an unknown randomly chosen
circular string of length n
and some constant deletion probability q
we pass
the string through the channel um and we
want
um so we can determine with high
probability what the string was using
polynomially many traces where the
exponent
is some constant depending on the
deletion probability q
so by random we're going to assume that
we can sample x using this process where
we
take a random string a random linear
string and we just apply a random
rotation or we just like wrap it around
and while this distribution is not
quite uniform on all possible circular
strings
it's close enough and our arguments are
easily modified
to work for that case as well so um
for the ease of presentation we're going
to assume that this is how we're
sampling
x so the main idea is um
to let uh k be some integer that's on
the order of log n
and we're going to construct uh we're
going to use the traces to recover what
is
called the k deck of x so this is the
multiset of length k consecutive
substrings of x so
we're going to use a similar argument to
the worst case reconstruction where
we're just going to test all pairs of
kdex and see whether the traces are
coming from one
or the other and to do this we're going
to use
um some string s of length k that
appears a different number of times in
the 2k decks
and we're just going to check to see how
often that string is appearing in the
traces
so this idea was also independently
found
by china doll in a recent paper
um on a different variant of trace
reconstruction as well
and then once we have the kdek we can
show that with high probability
a random circular string is going to be
uniquely determined by
its k deck so
we're just going to use the traces to
get the k deck and then we can
recover with high probability the string
from the kjack
and a string is going to be
uniquely determined by its k deck when
um
it's k deck when all the elements in
this k deck are
distinct so we're going to say such
strings are regular so all
uh we're going to require that all
length k consecutive substrings and
length k minus 1 consecutive substrings
are pairwise distinct
so then once we have the k deck we can
glue together
the k deck back into the original string
x and the way this works is uh
we take an arbitrary element of the k
deck and we look at the last k minus 1
bits
of this string and there is a unique
string in the k
deck that begins with these k minus one
elements so
uh we can glue these two strings
together and we can sort of just keep on
going until we
recover the whole string
so the probability that a string is
regular um
is going to be uh is going to tend to
one
provided uh we have a high enough
constant factor in front of the log n
so uh the probability that any two given
length k substrings are equal is one
over two to the k and we have o of n
squared um possible pairs where
uh they can fail so we can union bound
over all those pairs
and this gives the failure probability
of n squared over two to the k which we
can make small enough by just taking
k to b c log n where c is sufficiently
large
so now as mentioned before we want to
distinguish
between whether our traces are coming
from a string with
k deck s or a string with k deck t
so let's say those x and y are strings
with k dex s and t
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take some string s
of length k that appears in s and t
different a different number of times so
in other words
s appears contiguously in x and y a
different number of times
so if the probability that a trace
a random trace of x and we're going to
compare the probabilities that
a trace of x starts with x and the trace
of y starts with s
so because s appears a different number
of times in x and y
we can expect that these probabilities
will be somewhat far apart and
once we know that they're far apart
we can just look at our traces
and see what at what rate they're
starting with s
and that'll tell us whether it's more
likely that the
traces are coming from x or y or have k
decks
uh have coming from a string with k dex
srt
so now we just want to bound the
probabilities that
traces of x and y start with s away from
each other
and the way we can do this is by um an
explicit expression for the probability
so we have this sort of combinatorial
sum
over all subsequences
of the string
that when concatenated together form s
so for x let's say that c sub i is the
number of occurrences of s as a
substring
of x where um as a subsequence of x
where the subsequences
subsequence can be covered by a
substring of length k plus i
so the probability that this
subsequence appears at the beginning of
our
trace is given by first we want one
minus q to the k
for the probability that uh
the subsequence is preserved and then q
to the i for the probability that
the rest of the bits are deleted and
then we sum this over
all i and we also
divide by n because we choose a random
starting point
for seeing the trace as a linear string
so this is well approximated by um if we
just uh we so we have the sum here for
all i
from like 1 to n 0 to n so
0 to minus k so we can cut this off
we can cut off the terms where i is
bigger than much bigger than k
because then q to the i will make
those terms small enough where it's
essentially negligible
so now we have this expression one over
n times one minus q to the k
times this polynomial p of x s depending
on x and s
and evaluating this at q
gives us a good approximation for the
probability that
a trace from x starts with s and we can
do the exact same thing
for y and find this polynomial p of y s
and as long as p of x s and p of y s
evaluated at q
are far apart from each other then
uh by a turn off bound we can um
uh figure out if our traces are coming
from x or y
so if uh but there is an
issue where p of x s of q and p of y so
q
can be close to each other and in this
case what we can do is we can simulate
higher deletion probabilities
um by essentially feeding the traces
through
another deletion channel this time with
probability q prime minus q over one
minus q
so the overall effect is that the uh the
string goes through a deletion channel
of probability q prod
then we just need that p of x s and p of
y
s differ by a large enough amount on
this interval say from q to q plus one
over two
and so this is true by a result of
borwin at all
and um where we apply this result
because we can apply this result because
first of all the coefficients of p of x
s minus p of y s are bounded in
magnitude
so this is because c sub i is at most k
plus i
choose k because there's at most that
many
possible subsequences
times n and so
those coefficients are small enough
because
we restrict to i is of k
and also the constant term of p of x
s and p minus p of y s is bounded away
from zero and this is because
the constant term is just given by the
number of consecutive occurrences of
s in x and y so this is c sub zero
and we assumed in the beginning that
they were different that's how we chose
s so because
the coefficients of this polynomial are
bounded and the constant term is
sufficiently far from zero it can't be
very close to zero on this entire
interval
and that gives us the result so to
quickly summarize the algorithm
uh let's say we have an unknown random
circular string x
we're going to let k be some constant
times log n
and we're just going to check every pair
of circular strings with different k
decks
and we're going to compare um
we're going to compare
uh q y 1 s and q y 2 of s
over the interval of q q plus 1 over 2.
where s is some string that appears a
different number of times and y 1 and y
2.
and then we're going to simulate this
higher deletion probability
and we're going to check how often the
traces we see
start with s
and just like in the worst case
reconstruction
algorithm with high probability um
the correct deck will win every person
and so with high probability we can glue
the deck back together into a circular
string
and that's the answer
so the dependence of the constant cq and
the exponent
on q is uh we can take it to be o of one
over one minus q
and again this uh we only cared about
the
sample complexity and this algorithm is
very inefficient but there are ways of
making this
more efficient using linear programming
and china all cover a very similar case
in their application of this technique
so now i'm going to talk a little bit
about the lower bound where
for worst case circular trace
reconstruction we need at least up to
log factors and cube traces
so the idea behind this one is the same
as for linear strings so we want to find
two strings that are hard to distinguish
just from their traces and so the
strings we'll take
are um x which is one followed by n
zeros followed by one followed by n plus
one zeros
followed by one followed by n plus two
zeros and so this is going to be
some circular string where the ones are
roughly evenly spaced around the circle
and we're going to take y to be its
mirror image
so these are not the same circular
strings
but we can't distinguish them in
[Music]
less than o of n over log n cube traces
um and to get a bound like this um we
essentially want to
bound the distance between the
distribution on possible traces for x
and y
um and by some focal results about the
hell of your distance um this will give
us
the desired i cubed down and to
work with the distributions we first
note that if we condition on a one being
deleted
in the channel then x uh the resulting
traces of x and y
uh have the same distribution and
otherwise we just need to compute the
probability that we see
um one followed by a zeros followed by
one followed by b zero followed by one
followed by
c zeros um and this is a relatively
straightforward computation and bounding
finally i want to talk a little bit
about future directions
for circular trace reconstruction so a
lot of open questions remain
for example um there's the very recent
improvement of
um worst case linear trace
reconstruction to e to the
roughly n to the one-fifth so the
question is can we match this for
circular trace reconstruction even for
say n prime
along that line uh can we remove the
dependency on
the prime factorization of n in the each
of the
and to the one third upper bound we have
can we get a sub polynomial upper bound
for the average case
similar to the how the linear average
case is currently subpolynomial
and can we improve the lower bound
beyond nq maybe
even to a sub super polynomial down
finally we only consider the regime
where the deletion probability is
constant
um and perhaps we can achieve better
results
if the deletion probability tends to
zero
as n tends to infinity
thanks for listening and i hope to see
you at the conference